so if I don't mean to get morbid on you
but if you had died on the moon yeah
were we ready for that here in America
here on earth every president have a
speechwriter a staff and a staff writer
to the president would of course prepare
and the event some disaster unfolded
like Challenger accident and it's not
surprising me at all but one would do
that but it kind of not shocks but it
brings people into the reality so I have
some of those words that were prepared
in case Buzz Aldrin and Neil Armstrong
would be stranded on the moon still
alive but we would know they would
ultimately die these words were written
for President Nixon and he never had to
read them but they exist and they're in
his presidential archive fate has
ordained that the men who went to the
moon to explore in peace will stay on
the moon to rest in peace
these brave men Neil Armstrong and Edwin
Aldrin know that there is no hope for
their recovery but they also know that
there is hope for mankind in their
sacrifice these two men are laying down
their lives and mankind's most noble
goal the search for truth and
understanding that's creepy but
beautiful when those the guys were
coming back
they had another launch to go through to
get off the moon that's why they were
talking about them again saying on the
moon that rocket did not work on the
moon they were stuck yeah and I think if
if they were not successful I think we
would have continued and we talked about
that even with the with the shuttle
accidents I remember after we had
Challenger I became an astronaut after
that and before the second mission we
said all if you have an accident you
know that's gonna end the program and it
didn't you know we had another accident
and we kept going
it's American spirit and in your
particular case
you you were on a dangerous shuttle
mission we didn't have a backup mission
to save you
that's right and you did this knowing
you were at risk of death it was for we
the astrophysicists to fix our telescope
so I have to assume the answer to this
next question is yes but I need you on
record to say so was it worth the risk
yes absolutely you got it we got